One key paradigm in D3 that we haven't explicitly covered,
since dimple js abstracted it away from us, and
in all the coding we did in lesson one, we didn't have any bound data,
is the anonymous function as a call back, to access an element's bound data.
It's an anonymous function, because it's not given a name.
And if you come from other languages like to Python,
it's very similar to the lambda.
And I call it an accessor function because it allows us to
change the behavior of a generic D3 function.
Here I'm working with the extent to act differently depending on what we return.
So again this anonymous function is accessing the attendance in our data.
So pulling out the bound attendance values.
And since we're returning them.
The extent happens across the attendance column and returns the minimum and
maximum values.
Again in this case we're using the same d3.extent, we're passing the same data.
And hopefully you were wondering previously how do we get a time extent and
the count extent from very similar code?
Well the answer is the anonymous accessor function.
For the time we return the date and for
the attendance or count extent we simply return the attendance.
And while this function's quite simple in both these cases.
You can perform all sorts of complicated logic within.
And this is exactly how d3 makes its charts data driven.
The data bind, or .data function is only one side of the coin.
The other side is the anonymous accessor function, because after all.
What good is bound data, if there's no way for us to access and use it?